okay so the queer eye crew are getting
me ready for a first zoom date
so uh we're gonna um start this segment
with anthony porosky and bobby burke and
i gotta tell you
i realized something about myself
something very
powerful
sometimes when you have these
revelations about yourself not only are
they that ultimate aha moment but it's a
great place to work from
to start to
realize grow change
and i have one of those moments right
here take a look
when i walked in i noticed that you have
these beautiful little framed ferns yes
and do you know what ferns symbolize no
it's something about like renewal and
new life and rebirth and new beginnings
but i think that's perfect because
you're on this like new venture for
dating now
but i think friends are really important
to have around you on this on this next
step okay i like that i consider myself
like a humble home cook and i love food
and i eat a lot of it
um but this gentleman is a chef
yep i have to pick your brain antony is
there
any insights or
vibes that you have of like
do's or don'ts don't look for an excuse
to get intimidated because you're going
on a date with a chef you're one of like
you admire and respect and revere chefs
so i mean
it's obvious you know like that they're
in my marvel universe yeah
people are always so intimidated by
having um them over because they think
that they have to make something fancy
and really nice my friend beth she's a
chef she was like i'll like you can give
me burnt toast with butter and i'll be
happy just as long as somebody else made
it for me and as long as there's some
kind of intention there so i stand a
chance with this gentleman because yeah
toast i mean i can make a few things
okay can we talk about sam for a second
yes i don't know anything about him
because i always wanted to have some air
of mystery it's an
occupational impossibility yeah it's not
from an arrogant place i've done the
thing where i dated after queer eye and
it was kind of just really weird because
i was like what do they know about me
what do they not know but it's like just
go in and i know it's like such a try
thing but it's like just be you and talk
about the things that you're passionate
about any any other advice if it's
possible to just to like put that to the
side and just like just show who you are
and ask the questions that you really
want to ask to get to know him and i
really hope that he asks you a lot of
questions all i'm going to say is v
handsome
very much loves dogs which for me is
very exciting shut up i didn't know he
liked dogs at all yep okay we have to
get lucy douglas my dogs and neon
together ugh neon would love he has a
dog i could third wheel i love being a
third wheel okay so we know he loves
food you know he loves dogs yes i'm very
excited for you
first of all i'm so excited to pick your
brain um i have a really
what i think might be a relevant
question for everyone out there in the
world because when i found out this was
going to be a zoom date i thought
oh god that's awkward but then i thought
wait a minute this is what everybody's
going through everybody's doing it now i
think a lot of people do this to kind of
figure out if they even want to have a
second one so i've never done anything
like that i mean how great would that
have been in the past to have gotten out
of these awful first dates by just
having a zoom date first we should have
been doing this for years some pre-zoom
dates so my question to you because
people are in this zoom date
state
like what a great editing tool yes it
saves you so much time oh i went on a
date this summer i would have given
anything to it
i'm sorry my connection's really bad
let's try this again some other things
and i mean i'm very lucky my husband and
i have been together 18 years there were
no apps like we met on gay.com
in
2004. but that's hopeful because that's
basically it was the first game
online yeah yeah so you absolutely can
meet online where is a good place for
people to do a zoom date that's
aesthetically pleasing and maybe even
gives a little message of because we
think about the clothes the hair the
makeup but what about the space so i'm
going to say first of all not from the
bedroom
i think that sets the wrong tone i mean
if you want to set that tone that's fine
no yeah i think for first dates if
especially if it's if you really are out
there looking for
you know if you're looking for a hook-up
great girl start that from the bedroom
but if you're really good if you are
like hey i'm looking i want this to
possibly be a relationship don't start
it from the bedroom don't have your bed
in the background that's great advice
like it's sending a real sort of sex
forward message
and i am um
not ready for that
i don't know how to date with kids you
know i'm not there yet i have two young
girls and i'm like
i don't want to bring people home i
think that it would take me a very long
time to meet someone and get to know
them before i could even
ever introduce them to my daughters and
and i don't think anybody knows how to
do anything right so don't put that
pressure on yourself that you don't know
how to do it i think going into it
saying to yourself i don't know how to
do it is the first step of figuring out
how to do it because it's those people
that go in like i know what i'm doing i
got this you know what it's not going to
affect my kids what i do like
you're thinking about that and you're
thinking how it's going to affect them
and you're being careful about it which
means you're a good mom oh my god that
you're an amazing mother don't don't
question that at all it's the best
answer i could ever get because i
haven't admitted that out loud ever
i think we just went the first base
[Applause]
just anthony such a connection with
anthony and bobby you just really did
help me have this breakthrough
i uh i feel good
and i haven't gone into a date feeling
this confident
in a while
so i can't thank
you know
the queer eye crew enough for just that
alone
[Music]
you